oui cette table est libre oui à table et
oui la chaise c'est aussi à dire c'est
heureux parce qu'à quoirin servi la
libération si elle évolue finalement
voyons bond à 8 l et ben voila vous
prenez plus libre à la baballe ah bon tu
sais moi je veux des visages est un peu
cavalièrement monsieur mais descendu de
cheval monsieur j'ai l'impression de
l'avoir déjà rencontrée quelques ports
assez bien possible j'y vais
régulièrement
ah bah moi aussi je suis dans le même
cas que vous voyez vous ah ben ça doit
être là enfin entre nouveau mieux deux
hommes dans le même cas qu'un seul mr
bah voyons
oui ou 3 ou 3 dans le pétrin oui ou
quatre dans la cua dans la même
situation critique
mabri bon on pas dit mme à vous on vous
passez pas à bobino vous c'est un grand
music hall de la fcc n'est ce pas eh
bien là c'est là que je vous ai vu on
est passé aussi vous rêvez
c'est curieux c'est vous qui vous marrer
comme une baleine voyez vous comme de
blessés ça fait le poids oui l'étoile du
journal s'annonce pas très bien en ce
moment non ben c'est pas encourageant
alors non de mettre mes lunettes
j'en ai besoin d acheter autrement
servir d'abri on appelle de foot
l'argent des lunettes par les flèches en
ce moment il aime bien ses lunettes
ménage sa monture elle a dit c'est pas
brillant dans la rue même les prévisions
métérologiques ça n'a rien
d'extraordinaire c'est pas vrai
ah non non d'y voir un peu vous voyez
vous voyez c'est désolant de rassurant à
menaçant ah oui c'est une prévision
météorologique je voulais pour les pour
le prochain week-end oui les fêtes de
pâques et les prochaines fêtes foraines
de rassurant à menaçant de menaces en a
pas bien beau ne pas bien moi plutôt
moche est plutôt moche a franchement
tard tripoli pourquoi sur frau brillant
il ya ciel généralement couvert sur
l'ensemble du pays avec en perte et
belles éclaircies lui permettant de se
découvrir respectueusement devant les
cortèges et les défilés de cumulus de
cumulonimbus dolto stratis de cyrus de
ses pitreries sens douzy la suite russe
et puis les températures possibles et
probables
ah oui oui pour les régions nord atlas
où l'aviation est républicain wes
démocratique centre gauche et centre
droit sous le bras 37,5 sous la langue
38,2 ailleurs suivant le cas d'un baril
oui le buy in est donné un mollet world
ont bien sûr et bon oui enfin du point
tout ça c'est très joli mais voit ça
avec le changement de gouvernement en
tant qu il mène d'ailleurs être honnête
barres 2d
qu'est ce que vous pensez de la
situation actuelle map 11 passes
oui bien sûr c'est s'il vient tout de
suite à l'esprit mari oui mais quand
même quand on y réfléchit
quand on va au fond des choses oui
heureusement riche que d'y rester et
pour en sortir oui c'est toute
l'histoire et où d'une affaire et enfin
c'est comme ça et pas autrement elle et
comme disait celui qui ne voit plus rien
à dire vaut mieux c'est
ouais ouais bon moi je cois je me
demande où je vous ai vu vous habitez le
quartier ouais j'avais trop 121 avenue
du commandant jonathan les renforts
arrivent de tananarive
c'est bien comme cartier si central et
périphérique pour le prêt est une
voiture yoga tueur vous habitez dans un
essai s ennuyait chicoine et js kabylie
un immeuble à grand standing
ah non non une chérie tu risque c'est
que c'est une habitation à loyer modéré
à bruxelles c'est bien quel étage vous
êtes au 20e nous avons une belle vue de
la très belle vue imprenable sur quoi
sur un sur un immeuble administratif de
32 étages on va vous êtes tranquilles
assez calme au moins à wii wii fit la
personne de fruits a versé aujourd'hui à
l'origine on était nous avez quoi dans
votre appartement comme
ah ouais ben j'ai eu l'entraîneur rick
acabit ont garni et un en avant première
des serres de café l'addition
oui c'est ça le service découvert
compris oui vous avez une terrasse à le
broker a rempli cette agréable à 13
heures oui parce que ça me permet de
faire un peu d'élevage à vous élever oui
vous et des coûts à des poules des
lapins des escargots en écheveaux des
chevaux pour ramasser une grande
terrasse
les voisins du dessous sont agréables au
départ on pensait qu'il respecte
personne ne se plaint dit quand même
quand vous allez faire une marche
d'entraînement vers minuit et que vous
rentrez avec tous vos shows dans la
maison ça doit en bas n'ont d'abord son
défaut bien élevé au 20e pour en
découvrir
puis alors je l'aurais après ils sont
éduqués on le voit oui ils disent pas en
passant de nos frontières de leader eni
soit qui mal y pense comme vous les
prenez sur et puis la firme empire qui
relance un beau en plus ce sont des
[ __ ] trop de bruit des chevaux bien
élevé très bien élu et c'est ce qu'il y
en a qui seraient capables de faire les
livraisons tout seul à paris or pourquoi
pas et vous vous habitez du coup
port-cartier aussi un en banlieue où
seul un petit mpri coin charmant un masi
les deux pays
mais il vous voyez c'est ainsi très
jolie par la mise en val de grâce de
marne val de grâce de marge et charmeur
et charmant il avait un pavillon la
simple vision des jo publions ben
pavillon de la marine marchande à la
marine marchande et marine nationale la
marine de guerre a naturellement sur
tous les matins ou fait le salut aux
couleurs
non non non je tire un coup de galles
hureaux marchand de couleurs en face ils
sont bien même bien son charme c'est
mieux
les bombes a dit bolt en s'avançant nous
avons encore beaucoup de choses à nous d
henry ça serai demain je suis content
d'avoir de verdelhan
elle voit aussi valoir peut-être
pourrions-nous prendre pour reprendre
cet entretien tout de suite un prochain
rendez vous il faut qu'on soit là prénom
le tout de suite aller de l'avant bah
oui comme l'evo bas quand vous voudrez
bon et où ça où vous voudrez bon ok le
vôtre sera la mienne bas j'y serai là
moi aussi au revoir